now now Chibs a Pisa literally running
out the door did you get some bad Korean
barbecue chin i shat I should what you
get free eating [ __ ] 7-eleven sushi
bro i shat in my backyard after eating
clean how about jingoes I'll be right
back
yeah I've seen that look at his face
before we're in Australia all right you
got to take a [ __ ] he was sweating he
was sweating [ __ ] how that bathroom is
of disgust you can throw that bathroom
away every businessman drops bomb it's
not so bad there's no ventilation I mean
what can you do though what can you do
just not go in there and you know what
as a bigger man when I look at the
bathroom people just assume I took a
[ __ ] yeah no matter what yeah whatever
I'm doing that people just cuz I'm a
bigger butt wants to follow you but even
if I didn't do anything like like
intelligentsia that bathroom line is
Creswell be I'm dissing them right now
when you come out the girls just like oh
god damn you're like no I
I swear watch my house made that swear
man yeah the airplane is for I don't
know how you fit in the airplane
bathroom Oh nightmare I didn't have to
bend down it's ridiculous I do take
shits on airplanes though
what kind of savage take a [ __ ] on white
people and I stay in the ball oh god
Brian calm Oh God when the bathroom is
just salt like it's just I guess there's
nothing to do right guys just like it's
supposed to the airport bathroom guys
just no one's laughs I still find it
funny even I do this - looking at the
urinal and some guys like you just here
oh oh well I always find it funny when
the real business like the real business
guy here next to me in a full suit you
just go yeah hey how you doing it's like
oh yeah gotta pee fart just damn bro
what are you doing on this glorious
Labor Day Brian um what are you it will
usually do on labor days barbecues
I am yes I think maybe arbic you what am
I gonna do I'm gonna go to the I might
go back to the Malibu chili cook-off
with my kids here's the thing the kids
is actually a little
what's cotton candy so they're not
feeling so well the bounce off before I
get them to stop eating cotton candy
isn't that as a kid - yeah
and then it's dirt out there so they my
kids were they went in as sort of they
came out so brown but it's covered in
dirt but they cut uh the Malibu cook-off
is the actual cook-off of chili
yeah but the chili is [ __ ] well you
didn't even think about the Chili's food
stands it's rides for the kids but
there's no good chili no I don't know
you don't eat chili you don't know it's
too hot to eat chili when there's dust
everywhere my kids went in this kitchen
came out early and came out dirt brown
it's never too hot for chili well I love
chili at all times of the day the Sun a
nice like thick hearty chili little the
sour cream a little hot sauce or even
with that fastest [ __ ] amount Jesus hot
head and where's the fire what yeah he'd
be gone for 20 minutes so that was a
Korean poop used to you didn't you just
drop that nuke back to visit Hiroshima
bomb just move from my house cuz I had
my backyard did you uh chin did you uh
eat something bad this morning or I
don't think I had any food today at all
hot peppers last night I've had this
thing here just some nut yeah
just stacked on this your stomach just
doesn't agree with you did you have
yourself a little breakfast this morning
no my faster in the morning you fastened
this bro huh I like to fast in the
mornings back to the children I like
Dolce has a nice healthy hearty chili
instead of sour cream you can put your
Greek yogurt that's nice it's nice yeah
don't get me wrong there's nothing
there's nothing quite like a good
agility I don't like green chili though
do you know New Mexico's gonna hang on
for that no because I if you say chili I
always think of something red yeah
always
you know what's greener can surprise me
yeah i'll see i'm caucasian as [ __ ] so
he wants some goes no you only green
salsas like no it's all supposed to be
red you know though i do like salsa
tomatillos green i think but yeah i do
know you're saying i am one things I
notice that the Malibu chili cook-off is
did lots of celebrities you get your
Olivia Munn's you get your
you know who else Johnny Knoxville's you
get your bryan callen xiv ensure you get
you get lots of lots of different people
lots of lots of famous TV actors hook
off bro and nobody gives anybody a hard
time or is there with their kids and
then then Adam Sandler walks in my era
and how do you not text me right away
get to the there's chili and Adam sailor
this chili there's Adam Sandler brandon
loves and there's Booker from the
Phoenix Suns with his dick yeah you very
few things actually get Brennan's
attention and is the and hot women are
actually not what swivel your head
they're not
it'll be Adam Sandler or something tasty
we got a package today and it looked
like an Brennan it would look like a
bomb it was like this round kind of low
fee package loaf in brown and he goes
and Brennan goes well that either a bomb
or a delicious loaf of bread and it
actually turned out as those gloves
right there he's sick boxing gloves that
were made by Vijay met me with our faces
on it we both look like a couple of very
rugged must aggressive Russian gangster
he drew us to handsome you know that's
from us from when we did the spikes guy
choice yeah it's it's a great they're
great pics he's very good amazing yeah I
love that love those uh
so thanks Vijay yeah thanks Vijay anyway
I'm yeah you you you Adam Sandler well
here's the thing when you're walking
with your children you nobody wants to
be bothered
he's just to the fair the people crowd
around him beyond anything I've ever
seen you know it was so exhausting even
in Malibu the poor guy wouldn't believe
it
he just kept having to stop he stopped
for everybody dang he just kept having
to stop get up literally are walking to
get his kid on the thing he keeps going
okay and these [ __ ] over here that's
grown men just a bunch of people just
[ __ ] sucks man I just bothers me man so
come on guys [ __ ] stop with the
pictures with his kids on the holiday
yeah no i'm telling when i say when i
say he was surrounded by a crowd you may
as well you know it's like after
show after you do a show and you're
there to take pictures of people double
that lets him all the time all the time
all the time all the time so many famous
huh it that's what Fame that I'm sorry
but that is what it is
okay he's worth a lot of money villain
but even in LA in Malibu like this kid
you would think like I had some guy
tweet me go
you saw Habib I think it was in San Jose
he's doing his condition running he goes
hey I wanted to stop them and ask him a
question take a picture - in the middle
of his condition should I wait till is
that standard I'm like no no no
definitely wait till he's done running
or to maybe see him around next time
that don't stop them in the middle of
his work yeah those guy that what do you
do for it command someone come in like
so so sorry sorry sorry I'm trying you
have done can I do this like let's get
the [ __ ] out of here man even as a young
guy when I'd see like an actor I was
like it was like holy [ __ ] you know I
never I just didn't I don't know what to
say man you couldn't believe what they
were doing
it really bothered me cuz he was
stopping and he's such a good guy he
stopped for everybody look yeah oh yeah
my friend back up
yeah I'll say like it don't worry
brother I got you who are you I'm
security today the Chile event I guess
y'all do this friend Adam Sandler's
secure your security bro let's just hang
out and talk bits when you're good these
security guard for one day they'd be
miserable wide it's a good TV show
Brendan you're you're you know what you
want to hear a serious TV show and I'm
being serious yeah your security for
different celebrities for one day and we
follow you and get a sense of their life
that's hilarious might be the best idea
ever but then you'd have to have the
you'd have to have the sign of huge
celebrities they would do it they were
doing Inc a hundred percent they would
do it a hundred cent yeah Brendan Schaub
protects you and goes with you it'd be a
TV show the security guard and the
celebrity it's so stupid but it'd be
great it's cute and slow you should
pitch that as a show you're welcome
Bonnie fan no I don't want to do that
you would be there you would get their
door you would get them a coffee
mama he goes to me I know that that's
good about this because I know you he'd
be I [ __ ] this can if you want what [ __ ]
this guy hey you go get me
sure those guys don't get to me you'd
have to be a human wall that's like when
he was like yo which won't be on the red
carpet then we put a mic in interview
the people going on oh no I don't want
to do that he goes to bed later
no I'm not gonna interview celebrities
I'll be this I don't know what no I'm
I'm I'm sorry it's I think there was a
bad connection a cricket phone there
because it's a lie you said you wanted
me to one side you say walk the red
carpet no oh you oh no I'm not doing
that no no I'm out nothing the thanks oh
no that's not what I want to do no
thanks no thanks they wanted me to and
they said you got to come to the price
there they're looking you're on a short
list to host to be a host on The Price
is Right
dud be hilarious okay I believe that's
what it was and then the selling point
was she goes drew Carey
last year made six million dollars and I
went I know we all sing now if you gave
me twelve million dollars to be the host
of prices right I wouldn't do it because
I don't give up I can't do it I would
die would die kill my soul
she's like a creative guy like you carry
like there's nothing creative about this
show when you're on come on down you've
been on the road a driver and you did a
sitcom and you get older you don't give
a [ __ ] anymore this is easy you live
your life in the world you're shooting
three in a day in a season in three
weeks four weeks that's good point you
do it or do they do it they don't do in
life
no they just shoot a bunch my god it'd
be hard for me to be like all right Dan
what do you think there you got the the
Buick you got the trip to Hawaii and
then you got the crystal balls is that
more than two thousand dollars or less
yeah that's it god that's it and then
you can do to stand out if you want I
can understand it it's a day job will
you make you make so much of those game
shows you people they realize like Rob
Derek knocks out four episodes in a day
yes there's whatever say 18 episodes in
a season so that's what days and also
they they'll tell you you you will make
in that you're making a very short
period of time you get to a point where
your talk I know what happens they're
their business managers account and say
look do this until you have 20 million
dollars after taxes in the bank this is
what you're gonna make on interest in 20
million dollars on its
servant if portfolio is over things with
probably 1.2 million dollars or whatever
but still so you never have to work
again
so the idea is you just never have to
work but the idea that celebrities it
depends like sure Johnny Depp's manager
told that he's like what listen just do
these three it depends on your lifestyle
that doesn't mean you know it dies to
paralyse yeah people saying there are
playing field I can spend a million
dollars for sure I think it just depends
either way long story short I wish
you're the host of that I was sure that
you know you should do you look like the
guy to be a great host for cheaters yes
you know really gab yes I do and that
was you know that turned out to be fake
yeah I know but let's do it let's do it
but be real yeah I don't even have me as
a sideline guy I don't tell you feeling
right now Greg you just got cut get your
dick sucked and look were you out here
you're upset but they can't beat me up
so they I'm like come on Greg how you
feeling bro I can't be you Rob unless we
catch like Cain Velasquez of trust
around them buddy all right you want to
do it that's cool that's cool let's go
over here yeah you know what I think
you're in the right I'll say that I got
you know what no will blow to face if
they the celebrity and the nd security
and the bodyguard
dude the celebrity in the bodyguard what
a gorgeous culture no no no to use too
much just got the bodyguard great so
you're the bodyguard for a day no it's
just called the bodyguard hey but I date
but no I'll check it spin youporn get
your writing you can get all the gasp no
what I do is I just do hot girls like I
work for like Hilary Duff and Halle
Berry get close to me I'm gonna have to
get this is called shadows things stay
close I'm gonna get behind you work
there but really cook off I know let's
go in this dark low let's go in here so
I can protect you come sit on my lap on
this ride ride ride yeah I guess dad
look at him faking it I was amazing
it's all fake could you do a show like
Jerry Springer nope absolutely not I
feel bad for those people really I did a
show I did a show for four days they
paid me lots of money for
yeah called Bank of Hollywood and people
were would beg rich people for money
uh-huh that was great that was it I
didn't know that no I didn't know that
was what it was gonna be
they pulled a fast one on me because I
thought I was gonna be more I talked
soup which I wanted to be the host of
and so is II it was EE and I was like
I'll play there there there
she's a professional poker player
there's little mo silent you're the host
on this yeah that's Candy Spelling she's
a professional
Shawn Patterson who's a great guy who is
the Ron Patterson is the CEO of
Wilhelmina modeling agency I love that
guy why the [ __ ] down any pictures would
be hosting this that was the show
Bank of Hollywood yep 2009 yeah and Ryan
Seacrest produced it so I spent a little
time with him and I remember he made 13
million dollars a year and I said to my
agent I've been banking Polly which is
Ryan Callen for Gaza this goes up this
goes I'm not able to argue I will never
do it there is I mean they don't have
them on set oh there it is go you see
the fourth one in oh wow look at that
boom Wow yeah didn't have fun doing the
show no way that's not your thing
because it the people were desperate and
they were all crazy and yeah and they're
asking these people who are rich on
Thrones for money for the big day of
business problems they sneak in it was
like a shark tank one woman's breasts
was too big for their bigger than the
other
okay another woman needed a motor so it
was just a paraplegic there was like boy
who's 14 who was in a wheelchair and he
wanted to learn how to walk again so
they wanted to make him they would pay
for a pool where he would learn how to
walk again but he had a spinal cord
didn't it he was hit by a drunk driver
and he started to cry right there Jesus
I started I wanted to cry and I can't do
this you'd kill it was like y'all right
now losing her to me a pool this
beautiful 14 you know who was a hockey
player huge kid he you could see his
hand he was like this promising hockey
player and I went I was like I yeah he
had huge hands his hands well he wore he
was a giant and he's huge
no no he was he was gonna be you know he
was out like he was like sick already
six foot yeah but it was just so [ __ ]
out man
yeah that sounds like a bummer man
just came in to hockey right Jesus
Christ touched in the show and a hockey
player was just a bummer man [ __ ]
that sounds like about suicide more than
did not get picked up cuz now we shot
eight sir and but did all eight year no
yeah yeah
didn't work out yeah first thing that
pops up is it on you know uh Bank of
Hollywood season to click on that chin I
don't think there was a season to you
buddy Oh episode two hmm I can't watch
this now let me just get it let me get
it let me just feel it out for you I'll
tell you if you could do this actually
all I need is more money to be able to
help these kids come in and this is a
baby he's a great guy one second
you right there what's your name Heather
Heather can you step forward a little
bit please and Heather how long have you
been dancing here at the studio
and why are you getting teary eyed right
now I was like you want to get the first
color soup and see how look at me
standing there we're really the guy
holding the mic third oh you know I
don't even remember this I don't
remember this is so embarrassing
Creed I don't remember this dude this
show bums me out what they were doing
well you just said speaks volumes beg
for it go ahead beg for it and by the
way they would start crying these the
hosts would start crying the whole thing
was it was just spectacle and then they
go to you and we just cold behind the
eyes probably thinking hey this guy's
pretty flexible I wonder maybe he's good
in bed right it was 122 thousand dollars
to study contortion there's my girl
Wendy
who are these who's that panel 89 of the
Comus ones be what you call pussycat
that one right there she's a poker
player did you want sweetie gran can you
do that yeah let's turn this up any
strip club in our world of all time
Oh Larry's and I'm like another
incredible watch and back to you Ron
have that cue card and another
incredible episode of Bank of Hollywood
when we when we returned they said we
want you in a suit ago but you told me I
was gonna be doing the talk soup kind of
thing and they changed it under you not
audition for it yes it was a long
process but then but then you knew like
you thought you were agreeing I thought
it was gonna be like no I thought it was
gonna be yeah like like I talk soup miss
Crowley's offices off something up Paul
Smith suits for me who's your manager
they just they just they just I'm
telling you the day of the day of they
went so we're gonna we're actually
decided now I would have been like oh
I'm not doing that that's not what you
told me but back then I wanted to play
ball because I wanted to be I want to be
the host to talk soup it is he sounds
like I'll do this for you if you let me
do the you know that never happens never
do that
bokman and it's all good he was cool and
everything but I school experience and I
liked I liked the producers I liked
everybody involved I really did but I
just it's not my kind of thing no I
can't see you doing that now I don't
like any of that stuff it embarrasses me
and it makes me feel bad I don't like
seeing anybody in a position of like
where they have to ask for so makes you
feel weird no one wants to be in that
position no one no one no one wants to
even be in the position that you know if
you don't be surrounded yeah it's
terrible and we all of us need help
sometimes and all this need you know
yeah but I want to be on national TV
asking my friends for help no I mean did
he get a three out of ten yeah it did
[Laughter]
[Music]
son of a [ __ ] what I can't believe I
can cilenti they not find people sad
enough to make this show that's weird
that's incredible that's hilarious
don't fear police help we'll move on how
about I'm grabbing my own face I'm like
I'm on it see three out of ten
how about how fun was Thursday at the
Comedy Store
how about that group and we raised a lot
of money thank you everybody races
thirty million dollars speaking of
bragging we made him down the stage on
his knees exactly do the crowd gets him
why kicked them if he was [ __ ] great
how about that lineup how about how
about Bilborough her opening like oh he
gets out of his car
hey I don't I go what's up man you want
to get up you want to do some meters I
got it my set something I got no no you
got about an hour you want to get up
yeah go this is bill burr how modest
hero he's such a modest guy ago I go you
want to open and he goes yeah I don't
care bill burr opened the show Dober mmm
we had we're did they how about that
lineup it was all great yeah bill you
feel you deliora make it poor guy oh
yeah Theoden caught me he forgot yeah he
was so apologetic but he just forgot I
go do that I forgot all the time don't
worry cuz he got a bunch of like tweets
and stuff he's like I'm sorry yeah but
anyway it doesn't matter but it didn't
matter
no bill burr filled in for him yeah so
and so on instruments what happened to
see you I'm like he got replaced by a
gamma call car what's name bill burr
shut your yapper I could have gotten
Sebastian night Sebastian was in the
hallway but at that point it was just
such killers murderers row didn't matter
to get you and your boy listed your boy
who we raised the money for was how
there's - hilarious
what's his name David ollie really
really funny comic what condition does
he have Dave was born with a really
basically deformed of spine spy it's a
form of spinal bifida or something like
that so they messed up the the you not
can see him they messed up the years
various you they messed up the operation
he was gonna die click on heellenshow he
got to a point I don't know if I ever
told you this but he got to a point
where they they if they didn't make like
if he didn't get this operation he was
gonna die his because I was crushing his
long stride
here was the problem they didn't know if
they could operate because they didn't
know if his heart could take it so he
went through a year of basically testing
he finally did it and it's they have to
saw your spine [ __ ] in half your
spinal it's crazy not your core butts
don't worry yeah and basically now he's
he's a good now he's hilarious
he's funny guy too yes yes it was it was
some people really need help and they
just can't Dutch them there man yeah
he's been doing economy since 2001 yeah
funny as hell economy zhengzhou a little
pub chain could hate on the do agents
been all weird you can seem to standards
Lee you look not normal but you look
less you know every girl on Facebook are
you doing oh thanks for asking finally
he used to open for cavalry there's
nothing wrong or really in here no I got
a lot going on wrong with me it's just
not visible luckily you the only thing
wrong with you it's nothing wrong it's
just different you've got a shoulder
2015 surgeries I better have stuff I
don't know why your nose look great
[Laughter]
because their deviated septum but that's
just an excuse I'm only trying to help
given here septum thing that excuse only
goes so far like Chad Bono he said he
got a sex change because yes what would
make you really happy right now not
right this minute but like in this day
and time good help
I mean something reasonable family
[Laughter]
well I'm rotting on the inside so
seriously just good health all right
let's say you had good health the state
by the while this stretch of our imagine
after that I'm about to do one movie
that's all I want one what one movie and
you think that would bring you happiness
yeah I think I've even got a Thailand
for a title name that's a little
redundant but what's it called I've got
a hunch I've got a he's so great how
about that [ __ ] exchange god I'm glad
you played that you're Kevin Nealon the
guy who was on our that's not for nine
years the guy who wrote the host of
those famous sketches he's he you want
to talk about a [ __ ] comedy all-star
Hall of Famer Kevin Nealon is he married
yeah this [ __ ] yes Kevin's incredible
he's so goddamn it he's funny we got to
get him on the podcast he'll do it in a
heart rate he lives in Manhattan Beach
we definitely do [ __ ] yeah we'll get him
on got he's funny he opened up the gum
sure the other night cuz yes this I look
this is that guy look yeah how this I
got up on at the improv and I destroyed
one night it was I did my 20 minute and
it just it was just so crazy and Kevin
get something cuz I know Brian was
really funny and it's gonna take you a
second but I'm really really good as
well and it's not gonna affect how well
I do you'll say he he basically Kent
started out slowly and kept going I know
I haven't gotten the funny part yet but
you'll see I'm really really funny by
the end of it of course he [ __ ] was
destroying my destroy he's a monster
he's been doing it forever huh oh dude
he's never not worked and he's never not
been brilliant
Kevin yet he's alive in the honest he
Solaris an Adam Sandler movies - oh [ __ ]
yeah
now he's incredible oh by the way he's
been working since oh there it is 1984
ladies and gentlemen 1984
64 years old still still on the highest
level those guys really inspire the [ __ ]
out of me
ban spy you're gonna be doing this think
about this you're 3035 yeah you're gonna
be doing this until you're you you have
30 years if 30 years from now you're
gonna be hopefully you're gonna be that
guy
God willing do you know what I mean
people but geez they cool to think that
you can be doing this and keep growing
until your you die yeah hopefully now
you're not gonna live till you're gonna
die over 22 oh you know dude solid 20
years yeah I talked to this girl and she
was like my yeah my dad died of heart
failure I was like oh how old was he
he was 49 I was well well I'm two years
old no man yeah I was like well I'm 51
Jesus she showed me a picture I know
later it was her mom there's an older
lady and I was like oh yeah my mother's
she's very pretty but she was I mean she
was 52 a year older the hawk and she
liked me well just schulter if you look
like fruit well maybe I do too I was
like oh okay well that's the age I'm at
now you're a child kind of I don't feel
like it I'm good-looking
you're good-looking at what point is
like a he's good-looking older dude
probably now you think I don't know I I
don't what do you think Kat I'm I'm Kat
how old are you if you don't mind me
asking through debt when they're that
see I don't fight is it rude ask a young
lady hell with the art when they're
yelling I knew you were young
so that rude I mean I don't think
there's anything offensive of just
asking her age in general I mean if
you're 23 or 49 does it really matter
captain to write to them she has a
really strong grounded voice yeah like
like you could talk me into buying some
[ __ ] yeah she's got you you could talk
me into buy like a timeshare in Tahiti
yes she's direct and and so she's
grounded
I believe smart yeah she got the gig yes
yeah but do you look at right closer
here if you look at Brian and think it's
do you look at Brian I think old you
don't what you're not gonna hurt any of
our feelings at all not necessarily
old but I do you know age yeah you're
right I'm 50 I figure you're good
looking for a middle-aged man okay
that's that's all retain that and when
you look at me what do you think I think
you're some
of Mexican yes like a giant Mexican
that's fair that is young Mexican
younger look at her look at her she's
pausing
well it's pro sports for a time so I
don't know pro sports and fighting will
make her skin thick life will yeah I
think it's just like the thick skin on
your face I mean you think younger iFix
can you think younger younger yes like
if you saw me and Brian walking on the
street would you think Oh two gay men
now you look like a giant athlete you
don't think I look like your bunny no
you look don't think I would like you're
like your I saw still picture of him you
did one of those promos of you to stand
there like that like that me more it's
like when you see it with so many shoes
that are more that's funny it's a great
picture but you look tough as [ __ ] like
you you you you would you don't know
that stage son what's that that's at the
Comedy Store yeah but you're still a
giant man I'm a large man you kind of
look like his large sugar baby that's
what I'm saying kind of yeah yeah now
you're talking kind of playful so ya
know do you think that do you think I do
do you think that in some ways I own and
loan him to make some money uh you seem
like an older guy who likes being
submissive
well no no she's smart no that's the
[ __ ] wrong with it I'm a Dominic you
would think I [ __ ] Brian oh no I mean I
would you probably would in that
situated on Ninh so don't say that don't
submissive so am I like wrong with it I
know but am I am I on the so I'm on the
bed with my rumpy-pumpy up in the air I
just feel like as an older man hanging
out with someone that looks like Brennan
yes might you're right my yeah I'm
self-conscious of it all better have
dinner ready I better have dinner ready
because I'm getting older and and I
can't offer what the younger guys at
24-hour fitness or or or like but I
better cook up a mean [ __ ] stew a
mean or you better buy me my new Yeezys
or I'm not sucking your dick Oh got you
your Yeezys got you your new yellow
Yee what's your no cool what am i doing
by sticking like a wooden thing down
your throat what I mean
what's your uh I told you I never forgot
that one guy put up with the dick any
balls in my mouth
oh you're small I bet you could I'll put
your balls in my mouth
he liked to dress and drag I was like
okay there's my boy did I love me his
dick [ __ ] loved him
he was an actor in my class he was a
black thin small man impeccably dressed
and gay gay gay gay who was a he was a
drag he was a RuPaul kind of thing he
would drag dress and dry all the
performances he had a lot of dignity
sorry you're not reminiscent at the time
I remember you wearing that outfit bro
go to my Instagram this is a meme you
got a lot of you're just covered head to
toe in dungarees you're fluently
dungaree
right there but that jackets kind of
Jean but it's also that's a good look on
you bro the black on black on black
shoulders on you man look at that there
there is the big giant guy a giant guy I
think I'd low energy that night that's
what pictures like that you're getting
your standup is I'm very proud of your
standup I have to be honest with you
dude thank you you were with you were
with a group of killers and you held
your own yeah the night you did very
well
killers I'm serious man you've been
doing this for two years it's it's a
little bit remarkable I'm really really
happy with what you're doing thank you
sir
shut up shut your [ __ ] mouth it's
really cool though it's really I told
you when I saw Brennan we all hung out
we had a great time Thursday and it was
an incredible night and he gets in this
from his stupid Porsche you tell them
all that purple Porsche oh yeah and I
and I just you know my rims about to be
gold anyway scare no no you can't cuz I
can't be friends with you I can't dude
no no dude no no I can't shake him no no
do me a favor
I'm gonna say this is like when crystal
is no gold and sunglasses in a stupid
out those are those are signal chin
Google gt3rs gold rims can't bro I want
they're they're not addition I don't
want you where you can
in that purple car if your dick does
this no I won't take this can't do this
it's so obnoxious any of these click on
that program so obnoxious no click on
the one you don't her a little higher to
the right the prevention did please
actually go the slide why so it's so
gaudy go the far-right was so awful no I
hate it it looks terrible you need you
need more blame why don't you put giant
diamonds all have crusted in diamonds
while you're at it do you know something
oh my god my boys at shirt but I'm he's
got it he got his car and I was like
dude I'm just wanted to say for a second
I I was so worried when you were a
fighter and I was I would say to my wife
I was like well I don't know what's to
become of my dear friend who I love this
young man and I want I want such good
things for him because he wants the
world he wants so much and he wants to
be he just wants to be successful at
something and I don't know how to help
him because he's starting so late
do you broke course I did I just thought
it was gonna be a disaster because you
know how fighting is you know and what
happens gig and here you are here you
are [ __ ] old rims on my Porsche
I I listen I hope that's happening Brian
no no no no no I can't that is then I
want you refer they stupid expensive the
gold rims okay I want to refer to my
car's the darkwing duck the darkwing
duck not the dark winged dove no no the
darkwing duck of course just like a dog
winged of sing that song did you think
that song was darkwing duck
no I didn't rolled on darkwing duck this
is darkwing duck a purple gold bro okay
see purple on purple that's where my car
comes from darkwing duck darkwing duck
less like a dog winged duck quack quack
quack quack just like a dark window I
hear you come down the road
quack-quack damn that TV series only a
year long I'm waiting for the opening
night of that I'm calling it the
darkwing duck listen when I drove when I
when I drove my I bought a Prius a red
one I I made them call it the red Ram
the river and I pulled out and I had my
iPad my fingers in in a ram horn like
that
I made them stand there I go it's called
the red G and find the darkling duct
theme song darkwing duck let's get
dangerous darkwing duck
mooing I think so just like the dark
window that's a better one quack quack
quack quack darkwing duck intro here it
goes he's got cold rim listen be it's
obnoxious this is it I want to point you
in the fare hey dude
[Music]
yeah and then you pull out in your
Porsche dangerous put in a lot of TV ha
brother let's get dangerous darkwing
duck
turn it off right now chin doc wing duck
let's get dangerous sir kwinda you know
browser Rogan Joe Rogan was like get
yourself a 911
Tesla's nice but you got to plug it in
yeah the world's not ready for it yet so
get yourself and then he was pulling up
different Porsches and that that's
silver one that I don't have to say that
I but the problem is the back seats I
got kids I can't I can't be the guy who
has who stuffs his kids in the back get
it back your kids will all give it yeah
I know yeah although I've Christ sat in
the back exactly yeah you'll figure it
out
you're great I'll Drive you to a growth
you know each other's lap in the front
you see what Frank really I have a
challenger
yeah he's 800 horsepower yeah it says
boss level on it they made it for him I
was like come on dude it's so loud
row row row now does that come with trt
how does that work like when you open up
the back is there just vials of
testosterone it comes in with its own
you shoot smiles and then there's
syringes because you're circulating like
how's that work yeah you gotta have to
come with clomid and HGH like how's that
I don't know with those cars yeah it's a
little much it's holy what does it mean
to have 800 horsepower what does that
mean it means if you lined up 800 horses
that's your call that's so stupid if you
tried hanging on to 800 horses that's
what it's like hanging under your car
800 of them my car on the track the
system Frank's it does yeah I'm
don't be disrespectful don't be
disrespectful to his car
hey Frank cool ride see me on the tracks
broke what well his cars a muscle car
you're either in the muscle cars or
performance cars
I feel like Porsches just up you didn't
get dick into tits bro yeah yeah yeah
muscle cars are dicks okay dicks
well the Porsche is the handling and
everything I have intrigued now I want
to go test-drive a a priest pre-owned
that's what you should do yeah well I
love it'll forces for you bro right look
let me talk to some people see when get
you in the club yeah I feel like you're
in this line it's either better not
better
oh [ __ ] I'm freezing my car they don't
do whitener though do they
no but Taipei straight down straight let
me see the bottom it's still kind of
like yeah but it sits there not like I
got three more trays I know damn you got
width remember that one guy was in the
back way in the back now he's in the
front in the front I don't want to do
far front no not yet now he's sit in the
front row missing I just noticed that
I'm uneven Oh blah blah little it's
called Invisalign I'm not a miracle line
no it's like your teeth are still like
this I don't do that I don't like that
and oh there's one dip and that's
because this guy you teeth show like
this [ __ ] you little shorter you teach
to look like a [ __ ] level on
Excitebike but it's all good bro by the
way speaking of those rides I can't get
on rides anymore I get sick I know a
Dramamine I get sick I got in the
[ __ ] twirly thing that twirls that
belt you can't do Toros I guess grown
man you can't do I get sick like in
right away I get sick my kids like whoa
here's a tip and this is science if you
see a man who's larger on the kids ride
spin yeah and he's just faced for not
getting sick pedophile yeah I saw it on
Fox News
okay I don't have that yep I don't
follow bro interesting that if you see a
grown man alone in the line in con candy
but if do you know about the speed the
case the medical the strange and curious
medical case of the man who was a
regular guy family man great job
and then suddenly became inextricably
unexplainably attracted to small
children and we couldn't understand what
the [ __ ] was going on with him and he
knew something was wrong because I'm
drawn sexually two small children had a
tumor in his brain that was putting
pressure or dressing on the pedophile
button literally but I don't have him
cut he cut the tumor out that went away
he's in the dude know then started
talking out for real I've heard this
story I doubt you go got rid of two Burt
you're no longer in the kids yep but you
are in the dude a year later starts
getting the same feelings tumor grew
back took that out again went away again
then there was the guy who went on a
certain kind of he had a I think he was
taking heart medication and he went a
certain kind of antidepressant there you
go well as depressant and [ __ ]
didn't know how to spell pedophile it's
PAE do
paj who spilled that guy went on [ __ ]
out check this out family man kids wife
happily married goes on a certain
antidepressant starts [ __ ] dudes
can't get enough dude dick in like going
to bathrooms like into like bus at bus
stations and stuff and [ __ ] and just
couldn't get enough and then that turned
out he had got off the yes and won a
case for it yes the pills on this guy
had a brain tumor Utley made of my kids
yeah well this is crazy cuz you know
Twizzlers makes me want to get my dick
suck my hot girls yeah I don't know know
whenever I what do you mean cherry
licorice especially Twizzlers right I
want to get my dick sucked by a hot
chick so so you show you in other words
you eat the Twizzlers now you're like I
want really hot girls on my dad yeah
otherwise usually you're like this I
don't want that everyone understands to
like cut it subscribe because they have
huge was like just melon breasts and now
you're talking about [ __ ] glazed
doughnuts if I
that's what can I eat a glazed doughnut
yeah I wanna [ __ ] hot girls body stuff
so coffee does that to me Oh coffee
it's not just drinking it but if I'm
even around around it me time if
anybody's drinking coffee in general in
within they like well if we're clear
therefore being honest when I'm a
cellphones I want to [ __ ] girls this
that and chairs if I'm sitting in a
chair dude if I'm around my cell phone
enough I don't know what it is I don't
know if the new technology what it is
but it makes you wanna [ __ ] hot girls
it's only cellphones hi buddy
one time when I was a young man my I was
just I hadn't gotten laid in like I
don't know in these my buddy goes Brian
you guys you like girls huh I go yeah
[ __ ] like girls man
because we were in like we were in a
bikini or cycling and he's just like it
was summertime girls were in their
summer dresses and I was with he was
with like two other people and he goes
like this he goes this is so crude he
goes you like to go down and girls brag
oh yeah I [ __ ] like to go down and
girls bro and he goes you like to go
around and girls from behind I go and I
yeah I get like I said it he goes let's
go down say say you like to go down
girls like go get you like to go down
and girls from behind yeah embarrass
myself I was so aggressive about it and
he's like dude he goes he goes you out
of control I know I guess I am embarrass
myself the point is the point is that I
like to go down and grow from behind
only when people ask me am i okay that's
the point
yeah I'll call it a chairs and cartoon
you put them around coffee or cell
phones I wanna [ __ ] I don't know what it
is yeah that's time thing about gonna
talk to someone about it
yeah if I'm standing though and if I'm
in an immersion tank well I know you
jerk off in the immersion tanks but for
me I don't hate some people the guys who
own numbers and thinks me like a [ __ ]
sharp man it's not like you may give us
a bad rap well now you know yeah oh yeah
that's the reason why your business is
it yeah baboom in because I said I
jacked off in a tank one time you're
gonna get everyone's scared they're
gonna sit and come put any dude put any
dude in that dark dude if we turn out
the lights right now and took my pants
off nothing else is my date would be
ten-hut
my date goes pants off
let's get dangerous at that that that
let's get dangerous that's how that's
how will sasso texts jerking off that
fat fat f AP f AP AP sometimes I'll just
get up texts randomly fat fat fat fat
fat like seeing Willem forever he's
shooting his goddamn showing in
Vancouver yeah I miss him I miss him
oh I miss him too yet some Colonel Vince
Jin yeah I've got a few what's left when
I did the last post that will did on his
Instagram I know if it's last one but he
was filming something and then he just
panned over and then you saw like a sex
doll no no no I've seen it's actually
pretty funny he's been filming all right
here's the video will let me refresh
this real quick depending a dog and then
hardcore sex all right there oh that
looks very real it's a hot dog I know I
I would say okay now take a look at that
give me and be honest the percentage of
guys that would [ __ ] that 100 90 have
you know what does nothing for me no it
does nothing for me but I see I'm not
even interested in it
me neither but there is a side of me
that's like I mean what if it was just
like that
yeah like if I was really like okay like
okay I could jerk off or that's there in
my room and pawns on and it's gotta it's
I mean flashlight hole right you know
yeah like I don't have to do any work no
work I like I'm about to jack off and I
see that of the core my yeah I I don't
know but I am intrigued i I would I was
like thank you for spin you spin it out
see first yeah it'd be like I would
drive your car if you let me take it
around the block
sure that's all I'll find outfits for me
or not yeah I guess I don't know what
the holes are like another thing the
tits are you know what now that we keep
looking at it I'm not sure when when
Rogen when Rogen was sponsored by
fleshlight he gave me a couple I never
used one I never used weird I feel like
the loser you think that yeah yeah
I just I don't know I never used it I'd
rather buy
I think I didn't use ecause I don't want
to clean it out I just feel like a lot
cool
I know yeah I just don't want to be and
they remember when these old pocket
[ __ ] you can carry it around in your
pocket apparently you want to carry that
pocket [ __ ] around why so when I'm in
at the office I can go to the bathroom
and bang it dude have you seen sausage
party no you ever seen Seth Rogen
sausage party I know of it I swear to
God
you've never seen that no dude there's a
scene in there because it's like it's
like they're in the grocery store and
they think that everyone's in this movie
so they think when they leave the
grocery store they go on to like heaven
like it's the best they don't know that
humans are killing them and using them
as you know food and stuff like that
okay so good cast yeah it's hilarious
so there's a scene where they finally
get out in the real world and they see
how it is and there's a condom and he's
like I'm telling you bro don't come out
here don't come out and he's talking and
he's filled with come very far and
there's just it's disgust oh my but that
made that remind me of when he said that
it's so funny I had a guy who when I
swear to God I was a teenager and the
guy was dead serious he goes try this
he's ready try this I go anyways take a
poster of your favorite girl hottest
girl in Hollywood
you've got a hole in it and then you
take a water balloon you put it behind
it what you would full of full of hot
water warm water and you coat that in
Crisco you can [ __ ] it no she was like
dude that's [ __ ] crazy Crisco no bro
you use that for me he's just writing it
down really quickly did he say say how
many ounces of Crisco and he say which
poster was it Sally Field one is a
football players at Ricky now does he
have that exclusive Ted Cruz posters out
the one who wears tits are out this that
movie sorry I'm late to the party I just
know poet it's an animation it's a
two-hour long movie and it's [ __ ] oh
my god I never even heard of it right
even put it funny when you're high but
never look at that cast
you guys are amazing I swear to go
that's a great movie sausage party it's
[ __ ] hilarious sausage brilliant
movie what else you got Jen the first
one is this Cosmopolitan magazine cover
with a very very large lady
Tess holiday so I find this fascinating
because the world's biggest female are
anyways so I find this fascinating that
we sell like everybody's beautiful okay
okay I get that however we realize this
is she's sick like she's not healthy oh
good this is not healthy in any facet
correct there's a body shaming whatever
do what you want to do but to celebrate
this sort of obesity is insane yeah no I
don't think she'd be on front covers I
don't think you we should not glorify
being fat there are a couple things
going on I think one is the idea that
it's a fight back against you know it's
kind of women going look you guys are
creating this ideal that's unattainable
and unreachable when most of us look
like this and so maybe it's just a way
of saying there's room for this other
thing to what appears Morgan say about
it that the UK is already suffering from
obesity yeah
yeah and then girls say this and I see
it's like see it's okay if I just remain
fat and lazy like it's not a good
message man same message is these other
girls oh I should get surgery but let me
ask you legate Kylie Jenner she gets
surgery lips that's also equally
unhealthy the phlegm say and also how
about the fact that though though a lot
of women were starving themselves to
look more like the other so it seems to
me that both are unhealthy right both
are super on the right button mode on
the coverage you don't see those super
skinny girls anymore you know that went
away now curvy fit thin that's it then
curvy fit takes a lot more work than
starving [ __ ] skinny girl curvy fit
you got to put some work in yes there's
not a ton of stuff in one look at one
thing so then people go off [ __ ] I'm fat
curvy it's not gonna work let's
celebrate fat non-healthy the one thing
I noticed having been in this business
for 20 [ __ ] five years is Hollywood I
was always shocked as when women who
come into Hollywood looking amazing and
then they were just literally with her
nothing and I've talked to a lot of
directors about this they just stopped
eating because Hollywood you want to see
bones in your back and there was a lot
of pressure on actresses to do that so I
do think that actually you're right more
and more now women are muscular blowout
asses that's become the idea yeah I
don't know about this this is a weird I
agree with you like I'm not comfortable
it's lazy yeah you know you'll see the
men accepting this now like you know I
see a fat dude on the front of men's
health that's really nice women it's I
think it's radical like feminist
left-wing like kind of like the idea
people try to go you know what your your
idea of beauty is [ __ ] it's
depressive and that's oh I'm sorry but
there's nothing else thank you not
everyone's beautiful everyone's pretty
beauty's in the eye beholder mmm no fat
is unhealthy yes and I'm sure there's
some chubby chasers out there for both
for the majority yes there's a reason
why a Hyundai Sonata doesn't look like a
Ferrari exactly there is criteria for
beauty look congenitally blind men men
have never seen a women prefer a 3270
hip ratio they want a good 620 for that
you know that that's a fact that they
have that universally throughout all
cultures a waist it's small ways to hip
ratio is desirable by men there are
certain things asymmetry the symmetry is
is desirable even infants will stare at
somebody with a symmetrical face versus
an unsymmetrical
so the idea that that that beauty isn't
something that we inherently that there
is a certain criteria for beauty I don't
know if you know this but there's a bill
in the California Legislature sir that
is going to mandate publicly traded
companies mandate that they have women
on their boards regardless of merit
that's really have to have women on
their boards and Jerry Brown hit The
[ __ ] and all these [ __ ] morons who
are into equality of outcome not
equality of opportunity are like you
know what if you have a board full of
men you have to have women or the state
the [ __ ] government will put a
penalty on you this is government
overreach this is why government and
bureaucrats and government have to be
stopped so anybody who's into like this
this idea that government can you know
equalize the playing field well you're a
[ __ ] socialist and see how that
worked out pick up a history book
it's [ __ ] outrageous that is crazy
well then that is matted that's insane
your point your guys's point is that
it's not about a beauty thing really
here it's just that them putting someone
super largest unhealthy no but that's
not Shelby's there's no beauty here it's
a beauty magazine you don't have it now
everything's great equal now I mean not
not everyone has to buy that magazine
Zack you don't have to put fat people on
you put on athletic people on the cover
of Sports Illustrated cuz they didn't
make the team are you representing those
people and they I don't understand did
the fact the matter is if you want to be
on the cover of Cosmo yes you are gonna
be a an impossibly beautiful now if
she's on chubby are us I expect that
you're if she's on the front covers in
and out or fat but that said the cool
man it's a fetish there are guys who
like that it's small percentage yes but
it doesn't mean that we all have to
accept and go no that's that
everything's beauty no it's not correct
just Lao everyone's not smart not
everyone is a good she does have a
pretty face this one
yeah well by the way what isn't it
interesting her face is very pretty and
Stanton and actually goes into big lips
big eyes a lot of makeup eyebrows are
done here is yeah they're still they're
still copying the ideal just her body
huge titties yeah it's not for real the
big so there is a there is they're still
they're still actually copying the
standards she's still gettin in line
with the beauty model that's still yeah
but but she's way overweight and very
unhealthy and I agree that she's fat
damn it's all good if that's her thing
who gives a [ __ ] but we shouldn't need
to be on the oh I mean she's like that
is that fat yeah but again there's
nothing if that's your thing there's
nothing wrong with if you're happy great
I doubt it
I got she's happy [ __ ] but I know I
don't you might be I don't think you're
killing it you know well you can
surround yourself with people it becomes
a mutual insincerity society you can
surround yourself with people that'll
tell you you're great and there's no
it's like anything else it's like
getting a trophy everybody gets a trophy
there's no such thing as a winner or a
loser you can pretend that way in life
and it's not it's not it's a lie
that the problem is it's a [ __ ] lie
isn't it unless you're into this stuff
what else yeah all right chin yes you
know what you know chubby girls
Nawal of chubby yeah I like girls that
are fake but not yeah like you would
never try I can't see that being your
thing no no no my dick goes no but you
have no problem with large curvy but
Kirby's reveries always great yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that's that that's but
that to me that won't be curvy now
that's it I describe them in a shape I'd
say round yes yes that's true you guys
are like thin girls all right I don't
mind a pretty enough I don't I don't
mind thin
I dig thin girls too so just like do you
like some thin and weak I'm already big
huh
with dicks no one can fight back anyways
sure like I've been blah you liked Winx
you liked Winx she likes like Fleming's
black black you gotta be thin they gotta
be a guy oh and as evidence he's gotta
have gonads it's gotta have mad sense
speaking of gender equality we could
have thin black dudes yeah this thing's
crazy this pastor at the Aretha Franklin
funeral : and Ariana Grande
did you see this Brian nope cuz looks
like you didn't see this uh so a lot of
things happen here apparently ariana
grande got a lot of flack because she's
worn like she wore like a sort of a
short black dress yeah yeah she's the
one that stayed in Pete Davidson area or
engaged to feel and say yeah Pete
dayton's yep hey yeah this uh who's Pete
David the end up coming oh I'll show you
the actual video these guys did it well
the shade room she an african-american I
don't know
look at his hands hear me dude you live
under a rock he's got some long fingers
up my 28 yo daughter tells me dead look
at his hands of 16 he's grabbing her
when I saw ariana grande on the program
I thought that Larry under grande Taco
Bell
[Music]
girl let me give you all your respect
did y'all enjoy this icon see the bad
guy okay right there mistaking inter tip
I tell you he's got some he's got a
strong grip I'm saying some wondering
hair there's the ha oh yeah get some
high real kick some heat for this city
oh he's a high rib that's a high red
grab right there yeah so a lot of people
were pissed off about it because what he
is digging my daughter bags fingers are
deep you could tell she's super I'm not
deleting it she's and she keeps looking
like what the [ __ ] do that to me I'm
probably bigger than him and this price
similar size right yeah think about heat
you can just do this he went here he
goes dig into the size right there right
there but look on the titty let's see
who would do this weird to me but you do
this ya know get out of here bro
seriously don't I don't come on here to
get an award me too I've taken me to oh
you said you went deep you just went
deep bro you guys saw it on kamsa this
[ __ ] guy I'm trying to sit down these
four he's literally huh he's doing this
with these cool beacon my rump er um
nothing happens so no but he apologized
but his apology was kind of like lame
too he says he always grabs people like
that
it's a place about love he's always
about love but I don't trust any of
those child care guys
no no no sometimes you become a holy man
to keep yourself you know it's like I
gotta pray I'm gonna be horrible yeah
yeah I mean is there any is it let's be
honest for a second I mean if you look
at the Catholic Church and I'm guy my
family's Catholic I mean no we never
went to church but if you look at the
Catholic Church and you look at the
amount of sexual abuse that went on with
the clarity these these this was the
Catholic Church worldwide was a place
child predators hid behind the book and
the cloth and it's so rampant you're
talking about systemic you're talking
about literally the norm I mean and in
by the way it goes all the way the top
toddler they just had to pull that
forward it goes up to the Pope
yeah the Pope was like a new high bad
yeah intercept apologize yes I mean come
on Twitter sketch in this right here so
we talked about the story a while ago
about this homeless guy who helped this
lady out because she didn't have any her
car was like stranded on the freeway and
the homeless guy took his own money to
grab gas to fill up their tank and then
base they set up a GoFundMe account for
him and it got up to over five hundred
thousand dollars holy [ __ ]
what's he been money so the thing is the
woman did try to like you know give him
some money for this and that but she's
afraid she says she's afraid that he's
gonna go crazy and do drugs and all that
stuff again yeah so they're not giving
him all the money now the courts are
saying that she needs to pay the five
hundred thousand dollars so it seems
like it's his money in a way they they
just realized crap we have all this
money well that's a lot of exactly I
mean Jesus and in this guy do much well
like all the cast a lot of money you
could create yeah they're saying she
used the money yeah so they have to come
up with reports of exactly where the
money went
damn chin which she's been going on
vacation with her boyfriend and just
bought a new I think Mercedes or BMW
she'll use the money yeah yeah she's
[ __ ] right what happens with that you
say it's probably legal it's probably
legally gray my guess is it's legally
gray because there's no contract on how
to do do you use the money that says if
it's for this legit reason probably not
if she has a good lawyer she'll get away
with it well the courts already demanded
that she pay you gotta not be that dumb
about it but I guess it's just so
overwhelming when you have she's
my--like homeless guy with two [ __ ]
together I mean that's so much money
$400,000 a shitload of my 500 sir Wow
yeah now they're gonna sell that [ __ ]
five hundred they better start another
go go fund me I'm gonna go rescue a
homeless guy that was original British -
yeah rather pretty she's a good-looking
woman oh yes little [ __ ] chin
let's take a look nice guy this is a
crazy story so this couple here this
these parent these are actually his
parents okay
they gave him up for adoption when I was
a little kid he's a little baby because
what happened was the husband or what
I'm sorry so the guy here which is his
biological father and this woman's
biological mother this son found them
later on
years and years later looking for his
mom found out whose mom was relax it's
getting somewhere good okay yeah he
after he got older he found his mom and
his mom told the whole story I like they
his original dad before they had the
baby they separated the dad didn't know
that they had a kid Oh
so after that the son found the mom I
want you to read read the son found the
mom many years later when they're older
and then the mom was able to find the
dad they are two divorced now huh and
then they fell in love again after they
found each other that's good and the son
officiated their wedding yeah that's
pretty good
Wow that's actually pretty wild there's
a long story but it's still good yeah I
like that that makes sense
look at them that's interesting I wonder
if I wonder if that's in the day I
wonder how much of it had to do with
like nostalgia how long would I marriage
last this is the reason I left you in
the first place that's gonna happen
watch a couple well you know you may
come full circle dude so when they were
teenagers misdoing became pregnant gave
up their child for adoption
our net reached out more than three
years later one to meet his biological
parents missed him and miss Lynd Ergon
started dating again and fell in that's
a good story it's a great story yeah
that's cool man they got good job came
positive one chin yeah you want a
negative one yeah we do it's not that
negative but who does okay no so Megan
McCain I you know since John McCain just
passed away there was a picture
her a kind of picture where she's over
the casket crying yeah so some crazy
dude
posted a picture of someone holding a
gun at her face with a with a bad
message a real classic [ __ ] they
said [ __ ]
you mean classy classy narrow wait and
she they don't they don't want to show
the beauties a beauty too I'm John
McCain so they're mad that uh that
Twitter took forever true so goes yeah
the original posted America this one's
for you and it's a gun pointing at her
head why was that because because John
McCain was critical of Donald Trump and
so apparently that Kant that that that
makes his death mockable and you're
gonna mock his daughter because a lot of
these Trump supporters like that these
[ __ ] doughnuts they're not even
American they're just they're just so
bit the only way to means the only see a
massive Twitter is so it's so they're
like to try getting to it it's like but
what they said it took like six hours
half a day yeah and then they had over a
hundred complaints yeah and even the
husband play I'm a so sure happy but
have you ever well death threat on
Twitter anything have you ever done
report it will be probably have it but
if if you notice it in your report it
takes a while man yes I'd say six hours
would be fast yeah but there's people
who lacked decency they lack common
decency well no that guy is a [ __ ]
loser yeah it's a [ __ ] cowards little
[ __ ] yeah so keep going all right
you're the one ditches out there this
dude son heung-min who was a
instrumental winning in the soccer game
so son young men because he won this the
Asian Games he gets to avoid military
service especially if you get to be
Japan if you're Korean
yep Japan Japan that's the only way he
would ever realize is fine for a Korean
person cuz Japan was chin do you hate
Japanese I don't hate Japanese but then
what my parents tell me like a bunch of
stories do your parents hate the
Japanese my parents won't want me to
marry Japanese what if
what if you came home would just stop
blow out ass and tits japanese girl and
she's like papa you'd ever see i thought
goes deep goes pretty deep yeah and do
you know that a lot of korean a lot of
the Yakuza are ethnically Korean and you
told to be Japanese to be Japanese I
mean to be I mean to beat a cat do you
hate in the ethnicities don't say it if
you hate I said that's just big setup
towards each other yeah like we all kind
of de tribal group yeah like enemies
people don't like Chinese people that's
cuz that's cuz China tried to colonize
yeah my family members are also Chinese
they just don't admit to it no because
they were from Vietnam uh we don't like
the French colonization yep Koreans
don't like Japanese oh yes gate lights
Japanese and Chinese the fancier Asians
generally think they're better the
lighter skin they are that's everywhere
and that funny how it's all I think
Filipinos don't really like Koreans
right now because there's a large influx
of Koreans in the Philippines mm-hmm in
Malaysia there had been plenty of
pogroms there have been plenty of like
sort of massacres of ethnic Chinese
because the ethnic Chinese in Malaysia
are the we own a lot of the banks and
own a lot of the businesses and property
little so yeah so there's always been
the idea that you know it's just black
and white I mean you know being our
racists and tribals the only thing is
just black and white it's just you hear
the narrative Allah knows this is this
has been going on and will always go on
we are [ __ ] tribal human beings and
racism exists among people that look
very similar to each everywhere the
Sunni and the Shia same people they just
disagree on certain doctrines the
Catholics and the Protestants killed
each other forever
based on weird interpretations of the
Bible redheads bones human beings need
they don't need much to kill each other
what else get jinn nothing that great
just this I thought was interesting but
obvious Frank Fertitta during his
daughter's wedding
they had John Mayer
Mars and seal play privately Christ
that's a great wedding it's amazing
Wow god damn that's so much
oh you how to get Bruno Mars that you
like only cheap that's incredible that's
cool man John Mayer damn oh the best
concert well done there's one more event
but I don't know if it might be a little
too long did you see Joe Rogan meets Joe
Rogan ya know whoever did this edit says
pull that up onto YouTube it's
incredible actually this Play Doh met
Joe Rogan oh but I'm a huge fan dude
yeah do you like the edibles go to sleep
right a half a hit just were you like
okay ten of these accidentally not even
accidentally I did it on purpose
thousand meters THC know where it makes
you more aware more considerate yes
thinking about more possibilities I mean
that's what people call paranoid this is
a lot it's oh my god this editing they
did really well yeah and lazy and a
problem and they don't understand
there's a lot of pot smokers like you
are like me that work hard as [ __ ] and
are just adults it's definitely not
crazy no marijuana
no with these jumbo sprays the breast
crack oh my god it's the end of the
world
mmm yeah it's okay I'm gonna be so high
I'm barely gonna be able to talk yeah
it's a podcast do anything holy [ __ ] man
did all the zeros on that number you
wouldn't even be able to wrap your head
around it you'd be like what what's a
billion how many zeroes is that at least
a million trillions in a bill but
there's no way anyways it's really long
you smoke weed you ever get paranoid
yeah good oMG this is ridiculous at a
hundred yeah that's why I felt like this
all right
when chimps attack people they rip your
dick off like yeah no we don't trust you
like those muscles are like corded steel
for rip your dick off they pull your
eyes out it's one thing
it does happen sometimes you ever seen
one one looks like without their hair
what are you got Jamie leave this or
crusher Jesus Christ loot his balls
Jesus Christ look at the size of the
sack on that guy
that's a chip with mange that is there
some sort of a disease where his hair
falls off will you really see their
Anatomy this is reduce we antibody
impact but it's great
Sheehan says she ballsy that's [ __ ]
hilarious
yep that it Tim that's pretty much it
be yet you see 228 there right
Woodley who you got oh boy I'm your
prediction I'm gonna tell you what my
prediction is yeah I just asked for it
I'm gonna turn and tell Oh
here's why well Woodley's been out for a
grip as they say on the street and the
and and I think that Darren tell is so
much bigger and whatever Woodley has
with his explosive power is probably
going to be striking one indicated I
want to see how dare until does with
takedown defense but if there's anybody
who can with those long legs
I think it's tearing till how's it get
it done decision to kill not gokhale
that's what eyes but round what you
sniffing like that what's that mean
because it's very it's very tough yep
I know um I'm gonna go 4th round TKO I
said the same thing dude did you yeah I
think did until TKO yeah Harvey said you
call it fourth round I'll say second
mm-hmm I think if he knocks minutes
earlier yeah I think if it goes the
fourth and fifth he loses decision if
he's cautious like he was with Wonder
Boy then you know I don't know this is
gonna be interesting to see how cautious
he is how cost is how how afraid of is
he of the takedown
with someone like tyron woodley great
fight Tyron Woodley is is dangerous in
terms of his is single and double legs
are dangerous you're not worried about
his Greco you're not worried about him
clenching right dere until spry not
worried about getting in the clinch with
well he should be he should be tough
with his size and yeah he's been
training yeah I mean I'd be more worried
about freestyle rest by right
woodleigh's a freestyle rest well
woodleigh's been wrestling for since he
was a kid so he's pretty familiar with
Greco he's pretty fast my goal what I
doing the whole different all right
trust me Willie's gonna have the
advantage in the plinth he will yes
you wrestle when your kid being great
Gresham unfamiliar um yeah but his
expertise comes from likes like Jordan
burrows is great at freestyle trust me
if Jordan burrows wanted Greco he'd be
just fine
yes well alright makes sense yeah I
think I think yeah but fur till it's
gonna be again yeah not getting taken
down but I think Willie's gonna press
him against the cage and he's gonna get
Moses take downs from the clincher in
the case okay I think he's gonna shoot
his single leg and run him to the cage
gonna go to work from there and if Phil
can control that and negate that then
yet then yes'm if anybody can keep
standing up and stare until I'd matter
which I don't know we don't and there
was a fight where he did get he did get
taken down lost him a draw yeah well but
I was I didn't lose it he got double leg
nice and just brought to the ground I
went mmm this up though yeah he gets up
that's a good guy ready fight though
great right fight yeah bye so it's hard
to pick but I think til gets it done
yeah boom that's the big fight this is
fighting though uh home an event is Nico
Montaigne vs. Valentina Shevchenko yeah
yeah but I think we're on the same board
till Woodley yes sir
yep boom brother now I would leave for
New York tomorrow you do I I beg of you
I beg of you for you do a podcast try to
get Chris D'Elia in here so
someone yeah just for me and all the
fans listen they get somebody dynamic
don't talk about tennis books yeah I'm
saying no book no bookworm do a bookworm
I've disabled on yours do a bookworm
edition not on here though but not a
bookworm on I told chin I said tax me if
this is a guest soon the last time we
have blocks to do don't let me out don't
I can't figure out what that was going
on here hold the fort day now professor
John Stevens Neuroscience Institute will
talk to us about what your brain does
when you eat great first please hold the
fort down I beg of you I beg of you I'll
do that thank you sir Vancouver next
week 13th I just released my comps get
those tickets that [ __ ] is almost sold
out in Kufa the week after I'm in
Chicago 22 22nd Schaumburg the week
after that I'm in Bellevue watched in
the Seattle parlor live get tickets now
to fat cake aam and then October just
announced I'm at wiseguys for a full
weekend oh wise guy twice girls who I
like wise Great Salt Lake
Salt Lake t5k Tom get Joe can I ask you
a question no can I come and open for
you because of my family's right they'll
really that'd be fun I would I would
come and I'm sure if you're gonna say
that and people think you're coming do
it what when is it did bring up t5k
shows it's a Thursday through Saturday
I'm sure that's what I do that's not
what I'm shooting to 18th through the
20th I will know whether I have that
time off and I'll come all right dude
let's do it I can even do Friday night
Saturday so 22-inch 2022 22nd Chicago
Washington is 27th to 29th September
then Salt Lake City is the 18th to 20th
get tickets right now feel extra froggy
all things comedy festival Phoenix we
just announced a dish '''l show at 9:30
the semi clock is sold out with Ari
Shaffir big Jay Bryant Theo and myself
all things County Festival Phoenix TV I
got four tickets this the final kid
we're out